but we start off with chief
congressional correspondent Mike
Emmanuel here on Capitol Hill with me
with the latest on this afternoon's big
meeting we are keeping an eye on that
meeting the doors and when the president
speaks he's expected to speak after that
meeting
we'll bring you those remarks busy day
up here Mike good evening good evening
to you no question about a president
Trump pushing House Republicans to get
this done pass an immigration reform
plan this week Fox has learned that this
compromise bill that the house
leadership has crafted would take steps
to address the parent and child being
separated the border issue what's become
the critical topic here on Capitol Hill
if you happen to be a poor person we're
gonna yank that baby out of the mother's
arms
Democrats blasting President Trump and
his administration for blaming Congress
over parents being separated from their
children Senate Republican leaders are
hopeful they can address that one narrow
issue as soon as this week we're gonna
fix the problem the president says we
need to act the Democrats say we need to
act and we say we need to act so when
that happens yeah yet the Senate
Democratic leader says the president
should handle it mr. president I'll lend
you my pen any pen you can fix it
yourself Republican senator Orrin Hatch
is circulating a letter among his
colleagues calling for a pause on family
separations until Congress has time to
pass a legislative fix hatch argues
family should not have to suffer while
Congress takes the time to get this done
right border state Republicans say the
answer is handling the families in a
sympathetic way what we need to do is
enforce the law but to do so in a way
that keeps families together and is a
humane and compassionate way to deal
with what is admittedly a complex
problem but not enforcing the law it's
not an option at least for me on that
front there's at least some bipartisan
agreement if you detain him you detain
him as a family unit if you send one
back you send them all back but the
Senate Judiciary Chairman says president
Trump must be on board with any
legislative fix on immigration
the leader will not bring up any
immigration bills that the
administration is not not committed to
signing so even if we got 60 votes and
their president won't sign it I don't
think it's going to come up even in
unrelated hearings this issue remains
the dominant topic
are you not shaken by the voices and
faces of these children torn away from
their families of course I am but I'm
also shaken by the stories I hear about
about parents dragging their little kids
for the dirty you and we're the cartel
controlled territory there's also a
political component which could put
Democrats up for re-election in red
states in jeopardy all Senate Democrats
have signed on to a bill offered by
California's Dianne Feinstein who admits
it would not allow arrests within 100
miles of the border if that bothers
Susan we'll take it out that's easy in a
House Oversight hearing the panel's top
Democrat made this emotional appeal we
need you to join us in telling him that
we reject this mean policy the timing of
all that's heading into midterm campaign
sees it makes it a red hot political
issue and bread as you know not easy to
solve right and just back to that
Feinstein bill I mean it doesn't really
have a chance of getting through but
politically for Joe Donnelly of Indiana
and Heidi Heitkamp and John tester and
all of these red state Democrats who are
up for re-election to sign on to that
bill that's potentially politically
jeopardy no question about it I talked
to Republican sources who say they think
these Democrat senators we're looking
for an exit ramp from this issue they
grabbed the first thing they could find
and didn't read the fine print and it'll
be interesting to see how much this is
played over and over again going into
November and those races my thanks thank
you